so what is coq10 good for
i'm talking about coenzyme q10
now what is a coenzyme it's something
that helps an
enzyme and there's a lot of different
enzymes in the body that go way beyond
just
digestion there are enzymes that help
perform many different functions there
are proteins
that are involved in all the biochemical
pathways in the body
for making energy to making hormones to
helping you detoxify
poisonous chemicals now
coq10 is found in every single cell
in your body it's an extremely powerful
antioxidant but its main job is to
stabilize
membranes membranes are outer
coverings of certain things like your
cell membranes
have this outer fat layer very very
important in holding the um
the voltage of the cell because it sells
like a battery
without that membrane you would be able
to hold the voltage
so it's it's a very key part of all
cells
also the membrane around the
mitochondria which is energy factory
needs coq10 to help transport
electrons through this process
into atp which is the energy currency of
the body
all the lipoprotein membranes need
coenzyme q10
as in hdl ldl
and these are just proteins that carry
cholesterol through the body and then
back
from the body back to the liver so coq10
helps
stabilize membranes especially
in areas of your body which you're
generating a lot of
energy okay as in the heart
the brain the kidney the liver
and your muscles so we need coenzyme q10
because if
you're generating a lot of energy you're
also generating a lot of
free radical damage and oxidation so
coq10 helps to counter that now here's
the thing when someone takes a statin
they completely block
coq10 and if you're going to block this
enzyme you're going to create a lot of
side effects especially muscle damage
okay so if you're on a statin you need
to be taking coq10
also if you have any nutritional
deficiencies you're going to be
deficient in coq10
because that sets you up for not
creating coq10 in the first place
if you have inflammatory conditions and
there's
many different kinds autoimmune it's
like ms
diabetes you're going to need coq10
so coq10 can help any type of
heart condition it's good for athletes
that generate a lot of oxidation it's
good for people that have migraines
and headaches it's good for anyone that
has chronic inflammation
if you're taking a lot of medication
it's good to take
and also it's good to prevent cancer
because
cancer results from a lot of damage to
your dna
and so if you're taking coq10 you can
actually help prevent
some of that damage hey before you go
real quick
i have a course entitled how to
bulletproof
your immune system it's a free course i
want you to take it
and here's why here's you
here is your environment
everyone is focused on this over here
avoiding your environment but what about
here
what about strengthening your immune
system
that's what's missing this course will
show you how to bulletproof yourself
and so you can tolerate and resist your
environment much better
by strengthening your own immune system
i put a link down in the description
right down below
check it out and get signed up today